[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we
sister philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes I'm joined by my
co-host dr. Greg Sadler
today we are talking about lying is it
ever okay to lie and if so why is it and
why do we think that lying is a bad
thing and so this is one that that I
think all of us can relate to and what
bigger another because if there's
anybody out there who hasn't actually
ever told the why some time in their
life at least they've been lied to at
some point in time but I'm willing to
bet that everybody listening has at
least told one why at some point to
somebody and they're like I know I've
told plenty myself you're saying that
people lie all the time oh no as a
matter of fact they lie about lying
they tell more lies to cover those up
and we were just talking a little bit
before the show began about a story that
I was planning on telling and that might
be a funny one to begin with when when I
was in high school I had a really good
good friend who was a you know overall a
decent guy but he he had two big
problems both of which reinforced each
other one was that he liked to have more
than one girlfriend at a time and he
didn't like these girlfriends to know
that he was engaging in this so that was
the one big thing he cheated on one girl
with another girl and then sometimes
have three then he was trying to juggle
at the same time but here's where it
comes to our topic he would of course
lie to all of them and at first we you
know we're watching him and we're like
what's wrong with this guy doesn't he
realize that this is gonna blow up in
his face
because he would tell these lies and
over time they would they would start to
get weirder and weirder and wilder and
eventually the girls would figure out
and they would start comparing stories
because he always picked people who knew
each other as well it was early foolish
at his part then once they compared the
stories they would you know come to him
and start asking him pointed questions
and then it would all fall apart because
he forgot
which lies he told to which person so
this this cycle repeated itself several
times the first time that it happened we
thought oh he's learned his lesson and
you know he won't do this anymore
nope he went right back to it and just
it kept repeating this and and after a
while at first we tried to talk to him
and say this is not a good thing to do
and then we realized that it was somehow
part of his character or his his mindset
and he wasn't going to change and then
we just kind of sit back and watch this
stuff happening and every once in a
while throw something in there to stir
the pot a little
oh that slow-motion train wreck exactly
yeah
well they would there would be a fast
motion part of it once once somebody
confronted him
aha I wonder if he was more attracted to
the women or the the experience of
juggling all the time yeah you know I
that's a good question I I don't
actually know I mean he's been gone for
a very long time he unfortunately died
young in a car crash so he might have
grown out of it at some point you know
we know that that as we get older our
impulse control parts of our brains
start to you know finally be working at
full steam around what 25 26 and yeah he
was only 22 but yeah there's there's
something that I think some people find
if not necessarily thrilling at least
enticing about about telling lies yeah I
know it's a certain amount of like power
that you can derive over someone by
messing with their perception of reality
that's true and and one variety of lying
or deception would be like that's gotten
a lot of discussion lately is gas
lighting right where you're telling the
other person that don't believe your
lying eyes here's here's the the real
story
but you know I think about like for
example my mom also you know long passed
away we used to joke around that she
could never tell the same story twice
meaning that she could never tell
something that was entirely accurate and
then tell something that mapped on to
that exactly the next time that she told
us she always had to add something or
subtract something or change something
and that bothered us quite a bit as kids
because we viewed that as just lying I
kind of think that looking back on it
and reflecting on it she did that in
order to make the stories more enjoyable
or interesting and there's other people
in my family who that that I think that
trait can also be attributed to as well
what's I mean what's your family like on
on this sort of thing uh for the most
part you know there's not a whole lot of
you know tall tales or fish stories yeah
yeah straight shooters um see my
mother's side more so okay good
German background there I know there
seems to be some cultural connection
there who knows and I guess yeah I guess
my dad's side might have a little bit
you know I guess my dad would like to
tell a lark but it was never told in a
way where at least at the end you
expected it to actually be true it was
definitely whole thing oh I got one over
on you didn't you realize that this was
totally insane and that you should not
have been like going along with this in
the first place
yeah now is that a lie let's um we
should think about well what is a liar
yeah so oh go ahead we've got a couple
of views and there's you know you're
either you're an expansive view or more
limited view and the expansive view is
that any untruth is why I'm so this is
regardless of if you think it's true or
not so you know you believe the car that
drove by was green but it was actually
but you just misremembered you believe
it's green so but it was yellow yeah
many people would call that not a lie
but there's an expansive you with that
would be a lie and the delimited is a on
to make a believed false statement to
another person with the intention that
the other person believed that statement
to be true so this is you know it's
false then you convey it making the
other person think that it's true while
you are expressly knowing that it's
false so that raises a lot of
interesting limit cases where we might
think about a fiction for example right
if fiction or if you think about like
media production like movies and TV
shows if if it's really effective we we
do in some sense think that it's true at
least while we're watching the movie or
reading the novel because we allow
ourselves to be affected by it as if it
were true and at the same time we can we
can we can withdraw from it we're not
we're not stuck in it right
maybe that's the maybe that's the
important distinction if I wanted if I'm
watching a horror movie for example a
great example of this is the the
American version of the garage that's a
really scary one in part because of
those scenes where the the girl comes
out of the TV because that that kind of
implies that maybe she could be also
coming out of your TV now of course the
rest of the technology is very dated you
know I think it was a was it a VCR or
tape and a tube TV yeah so nobody
nobody's gonna be using that anymore but
the basic idea of it being something
scary and we're watching it but it's
it's it's essentially lying to us
telling us things that are untrue and
deliberately so so that we can enjoy it
that were able to go ahead it reminds me
of the Blair Witch Project which also
blurs the line even more because the
entire thing was the more it was
marketed as this was true footage found
and they didn't break that lie through
you know years after the original film
was put out but we can still turn off
the TV or streaming or whatever it is if
we want to we can withdraw outside of
that whereas maybe the deception thing
is more about the unavoidability of
buying into it you know so if I tell you
that you know something about kovat 19
that that you can get it I don't know
through looking at somebody else has got
kovin 19 which is clearly false now you
can choose not to listen to me and say
well that guy's full of it but if you do
in fact view me as somebody who's
generally truthful then I can deceive
you and then you're stuck with the
consequences of being deceived like
you're going around covering your eyes
every time you see somebody who might be
sick and like a more real world
experience of this was the AIDS crisis
and the lies are told yeah who could
actually contract that and like how a
how contagious it was which it isn't
very yeah yeah that is actually a great
example and we can think of all sorts of
lies that people tell each other but
coming back to this like expansive
versus limited view so where do you fall
in on this are you more on the expansive
side saying well if it's fun if it's
false it's a lie you know or or do you
think it matters what the person's
motives are and I'm a limited view and
what I call a lie it doesn't mean that
untruths are any the the outcomes might
be worse with the untruth okay it
doesn't doesn't make the other one
better
it just it changes maybe the way that
you react to the person that's doing it
and yeah what one the why I would feel
negatively about that person it would
changed my view about them because they
are intentionally acting against me
whereas the one who tells an untruth
either they
need help - oh try to reconfigure their
way of their epistemology or how they
know what is true and and so it's a much
more like oh let me help you versus Oh
get away from me you're doing something
negative towards me you know I remember
when I was a kid I think I had a more
expansive view of lies because I
remember going to movies in particular
and being very upset at what I perceived
to be lies so great example of this
would be we went to see Indiana Jones in
the Temple of Doom and we saw it in the
theater and I I don't remember what age
I was but I knew something about the
thuggees and the kali sect and I was
like that's wrong you know we went on
the theater and everyone else great
movie and I was like there that I didn't
say they're telling lies but I said
something like that you know and there
were other like Clash of the Titans is
another great example so I was I was
quite bothered by the distortions of
Greek mythology which is a bunch of lies
- anyway even even the ancient Greeks
often talked about about those stories
as being a pack of lies results and and
I was I was very upset about the fact
that somebody was blending together
different characters and motifs so I
think there are quite a few people who
do have an expansive view of oh yeah
I've had yes had to deal with people
like that it's it's actually really
difficult because everything is bad yeah
all the time basically and there's
there's very little dated
grey area you know when you have a
purely expensive you it's like
everything is bad because you should
everything has some untruth to it right
and also everyone is deserving in the
same amount of punishment for saying
something that is untrue versus that of
why so this is a good segue into talking
about another distinction that that gets
made in terms of motives the reasons why
people lie and I think we've all heard
of white lies and then you know
corresponding to that would be black
lies so you know good and white lies are
usually viewed as lies that if they're
not just if they're not actually good
they're at least not bad you know we we
tell people things that save their
feelings like if somebody says hey how
is my my talk that I gave and you know
you could say to them oh not good at all
I mean you did not communicate
effectively the audience you lost them
at you know the five minute mark but you
know unless unless you they're gonna
help improve their performance what good
does that do you're just hurting their
feelings so maybe you tell them
something like you know it was pretty
good you know you don't say oh the best
thing I ever saw but you know you you
you spare people's feelings right or we
have all sorts of little lies that we
tell to sort of like you might say fill
in the gaps and in stories or or you
know lubricate the social machines so
that we can not come into conflict with
each other you don't actually like hang
out with this person but you have to at
work and so you you lie and you say that
they're you know they're an interesting
person to talk to
now a lot so you know it with the
expanse of you that would just be
terrible right because it's still alive
but a lot of people think that that
white lies are just fine it's it's black
lies that they have a problem with when
somebody lies for selfish reasons and it
could be about we thought you mentioned
power earlier lies are one way to get
power over people right you control the
the information but it could also be to
make yourself look good or to gain some
sort of monetary advantage over somebody
or or just go hurt someone yeah as you
want to to be that malicious and so
we've got this distinction here that you
got down you know white lies are the for
you lies there's other people and the
black lies are you know formulize yeah
now recently people have started
talking about a third kind of lie and I
think this is actually quite helpful as
a distinction they call them blue lies
and I'm almost have to say blue lies
matter and I think in part they the
notion of blue did in fact come from the
fact that police will sometimes lie to
protect other police it's it's a quite a
problem at some points and a so a blue
lie has to do with lying for the benefit
of your your group your community or
maybe your family or your profession or
the other people that you identify with
and you know sports teams kind of do
this too right they they try to deceive
each other about what they're gonna do I
was gonna say like as a fan you're like
oh the ref is totally blind even though
that was a fair call and you'll try to
make your cases like it should have been
totally reversed even though that's you
know maybe not as objective as you could
be you know so we'll take a little
detour here in talking about sports fans
because I think you're completely right
about that but I also think that sports
fans also lie routinely about how bad
their team and its players are you know
they'll say that they're they're not
playing up to potential and they spent
too much money on this person here and
you know they have all sorts of Monday
morning quarterbacking or football or
whatever the equivalent is for baseball
or you know things things like that so I
think the lying can be both like in
favor of your team but there's also a
kind of lying with it with an in-group
about like how bad your team is and and
you know we see this - with people
razzing each other right you you say
things to people in your in-group that
would not be appropriate to people
outside of it and although that is wise
and and some that's also very dependent
upon the group in the norms within that
group because there are certain groups
that that is totally normal and then
some of the groups that would be you
know totally beyond the pale have you
ever made the mistake of thinking here
and one of those groups
and then finding the area the other on I
guess I tend to be the one that's not
razzing and so I don't usually fall into
the that particular faux pas I've made
that mistake before
[Laughter]
but anyway going back to blue lies so
they're they're told in order to benefit
those that you you identify with and
they're usually in some way directed
against people who aren't in your your
group they it might be just a sort of
generic way like you're favoring your
group over other people but it could be
like saying things that are you know
false about your group to the detriment
of another group of people or you could
be you just telling lies about other
groups or communities in order to
benefit your own so oh good for example
this is like our spies we hail the
people that work for the CIA as heroes
that they fall when the lion duty they
get there like a star up at Langley and
we have a long history but these people
are inherently lying all the time in our
benefit as a nation group if you will
and I'm and is a really interesting one
because when other when other groups do
it then we don't have that same sort of
sanguine attitude towards that we're
like those dirty you know deceptive
spies they're coming in and corrupting
our wonderful truthful country you know
or we don't like when they're lying
spies go after our lying spies you know
right and one of the interesting things
about this is not only is it like it's
post Pro social within the group and
it's anti-social for those people
outside of the group but you can say
well you said to yourself earlier like
lies within the group on but those lies
actually create more cohesion within the
group because it gives something that we
all hold that no one else holds and you
can turn it into a group dynamic of like
uh sources em cuz like we hold this
thing to be truth and everywhere else
like what are you crazy
yeah that's that's quite quite true so
where do where should we stand I mean
black lives we can agree those are bad
we shouldn't we shouldn't engage in
those we should condemn them you know we
should try to uncover them what about
white lies what about what about blue
lies what do you think so if you go
about last week in our circles concern
if you're cosmopolitan then the blue
lies are out because the idea is that
you should be caring about everyone and
not just individual groups I guess I
fault more towards that and then white
lies you know what I guess I I would
constrain the amount of white lies that
I would do do a very small group and not
just like saving one's feelings but I
think that you know if you had to kind
of Whittle it down close to that of your
I was a Helen Keller situation you know
someone comes and knocks on the door and
they're going to want to murder someone
they say if there are they there then
I'm like yeah why then okay yeah so
lives to protect important values you
could say so maybe maybe saving face or
sparing feelings isn't as important of a
value maybe except maybe in certain
cases like you know you see somebody
who's like totally devastated and one
you know engaging in one more harsh
truth would like break them
maybe maybe then you tell tell the white
lie right yeah I guess for a lot of the
white lies it's kind of the difference
between volunteering the the comment or
not and I guess I would more just like
not volunteer the positive comment yeah
then say something course there's
there's a great thing that I guess could
be considered a white lie in some
respect all that was self-serving it's a
famous story about Athanasius
this this Orthodox you know monk divine
Bishop and when the non-orthodox Aryans
dominated the eastern Roman Empire and
they were seeking they're they're trying
to find him he was on the river and
they're trying to find him because they
were gonna kill him
and he's going up the river and there's
a boatload of soldiers coming down I
think from Alexandria and they they
shout out to him and they say is have
you seen or is Athanasius nearby and he
tells them you're you're not far now
from him keeps on sailing now he
deceived them right so there there was
an intent to deceive by saying that he
didn't explicitly lie he didn't say
anything that was actually untrue as a
matter of fact he said something that
was quite clearly true but he said it in
such a way as to mislead them is it a
lie
and is that a white lie what do you
think it it's definitely a lie at least
okay constrained narrow thing because
the intent is to mislead them and is
that why I don't know it's it's not
doing it for someone else so it's not
pro-social I guess that's how we were
kind of defining our white lies you know
I mean he matters to the community that
he's a you know a representative of I
suppose but you know I think he's doing
it essentially to save himself and in
part because he didn't want those other
people who to be able to do the wrong
thing I guess you could say he's
actually in some respect helping them
out to not do something wrong although
they they want to do something wrong
this is this would be a good one
actually we could think about other
cases to like should you lie to the
junkie or the alcoholic who who wants to
get to the stuff that's actually in the
apartment that you're in should you lie
and tell them that there isn't any
stuff I say you should myself yeah you
could definitely look at that as a
pro-social if you're trying to make sure
that he's not gonna get all off junk and
then Mordor knows he's like that's the
idea yeah so maybe let's move on to like
big and little wise cuz this is also
another distinction here
that's what how do you draw that one
that's kind of a hard one like it's most
white lies are little wise because
you're like you know saving the that
emotional state or something about a
person but like the big lies are the
ones with big consequences and they like
this is also we're just talking about
life and death things and those are big
consequences and you know the bigger the
lie you know look at weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq or so it's a it's
the content and the consequences that
make it bigger little done yes it's not
just like so I mean I could I could tell
a real whopper as we say about some
trivial matter couldn't I like I say
that my you know my hangnail is gonna
cause me to die tomorrow or something
like that you know clearly over the top
kind of thing is that a big liar is that
a little lie that's a little why ok
anyway it's not like the amount of help
leighton lee false it is it's the the
consequences of like especially life or
death or so so if I tell you let's say
you're married and I tell your wife you
know some big story about how you've
been cheating on her and I like
manufacture some text dreams or
something like that that's a big lie
alright guys that's that's gonna get you
in a lot of hot water and cause a great
rift does that mean then that the sort
of we were talking about razzing or
telling stories that those sort of
automatically become small because the
consequences to that are kind of small
yes in this particular diet like
distinction okay that makes sense to me
and but both of them can have bad
outcomes
this is the magnitude of that bad
outcome yeah
so there I know you wanted to talk about
a lot of the negative consequences to
lying and you've got quite a few things
sort of in reserve here for us to go
right which would you say are the the
most important bad consequences eroding
trust and self-deception and just
generally pulling us away from a more
objective world okay and so if I will
like the idea is white lies like you're
doing them and you're trying to do them
to do something that's pro-social but
the problem is that if you are doing all
these little white lies are pro-social
once other people see that you can
easily say these things with like little
worried about them and at the drop of
the Hat why then all of a sudden it
makes everything else you say suspect
and now you're now roading the trust
that you have with them you know like
this what when the says like oh I can't
like meet you up on Friday like you know
I had to take the car into the mechanic
it was like it's that person actually
lying to me or not like what is the
basis of their reality and why they're
gonna say things I think that you can
say that that not only erodes the trust
within that relationship but also in
others so like if you see me let's say
we're sitting at the coffee shop right
and we're chatting about what we're
gonna do for the show and like in a
phone call and I
I say something that you know is is
untrue like I'm saying
yeah I'm not at the coffee shop I'm
actually like getting my oil changed and
you look at me what's what's going on
here and afterwards I get off and I say
yeah I just can't tell them that I was
at the coffee shop because they really
don't like coffee shops and to tell
something you would actually look at me
and be like well so that guy tends to
make up stories whenever he thinks it's
convenient and now you could like look
at me and be like well I don't like him
for that reason but you could also be
like that's not a bad idea actually I
should try that sometime the next time
you know and if we think about certain
relationships that we have where think
about teachers and students or a boss
and employees or you know parents and
children anything where there's like a
power imbalance when we see the people
who are higher up lying routinely then
it seems like it's it's okay right and
normalize exactly that's a good way to
put it yeah yeah and one of the things
is like we have a negative a negativity
bias and so we're much more attuned to
those bad things it's like you know
someone cut you off or like clipped you
off or something and you you dwell on
that much more than the good things and
there's a an interesting paper by Roy f
bow master and Ellen broad Slav ski on
which is called bad is stronger than
good and one of the conclusions they did
from their research was that there's
about a four to one margin of those bad
things to good things so well it once
you have a bad impression about someone
and you kind of like start to maybe
attribute an idea of the bad to them
because you see them doing bad things
like this example of the lying and yeah
it takes so much more to overcome that
to overcome that now I know you know
four times as much good things to say oh
yeah he's actually a pretty good guy
even though he lies sometimes or so well
that's interesting because that in that
you know there's this like sort of
old-fashioned view of like you're your
honor or your truthfulness or your
integrity as being this this thing that
you can't afford to damage or tarnish
and that would that would suggest that
there is really something to that right
okay then then you you have to like
scrub the floors or something for a
while until you get back into someone's
good graces yeah and the last thing is
like really that you know we have only
one way to improve ourselves and that is
to be really aware of the state that we
are in the world the world around us and
how we're interacting with it and if we
are constantly being given bad
information about this then we have no
ability to objectively interact with the
world you see this all the time
yeah like America's Got Talent you see
those people that think that they're
such amazing singers because all their
friends and family have just never had
the ability to actually say no you're
not good and then they yeah embarrass
themselves on national television dant
is actually a problem interestingly
enough talking with people who work in
the art field and who work in the music
field where because you know you come up
through high school first before you go
to like you know Berklee School of Music
or Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
and quite often in high school you're
the proverbial big fish in a small pond
you're the talented artist person and
people are telling you how great you are
and and what you're hearing is oh I'm so
amazing when you usually they're saying
oh you have so much potential you need
to go somewhere and cultivate that
potential that you've got you know it'll
be so much better for you when you've
put in four years of this and so they
they come in and quite often they're
like I don't need to take a drawing
class
I already did drawing back in high
school and they're like no you know you
really need to learn the techniques
properly and it's the same thing with
like people who come in I've got a
friend who's a guitar professor he says
the constant problem with with these
kids coming in who have like made
YouTube videos of themselves playing and
they're like shredding something and
he's like okay you don't know the basic
music theory
you've got to actually study this stuff
and do these drills and by the way you
learned how to finger stuff wrong and
now you've got to unlearn that you know
and so having having been told things
that weren't strictly speaking lies but
which they processed wrong maybe Manaus
is that lying to themselves in in doing
that and telling themselves oh I'm much
further along than then they really are
I'm a better musician I'm a better
drafts person than that I actually am
that that certainly impedes them is is
it is it a case of lying to themselves
in the strict sense no but definitely
you know and it might even not be of a
strict sense for the people that are
telling them that they're good they
might have some really good talent and
in respect to what they know as
musicians there are non musician they
probably sound really good but they
don't have the the background to
actually make a valid assessment of that
so I guess that kind of goes down to
that that dunning-kruger effect that the
the less you know about something the
more you feel like you are have
qualification to do or assess something
yeah
now I'm going to go off on a little
tangent here if you if you make a
statement about something that you're
you're not an expert in and you don't
don't really know that much about and it
turns out to be false and you you you
could have learned you know otherwise
but you didn't put in the time are you
telling a lie in that case
how authoritative Lee are you saying
this that's a good question Wow so so
the person who's like oh man yeah you
rock you're so good you know maybe maybe
they they're they're not speaking in any
authoritative manner they're just
talking like a fan so maybe there's less
of an onus there but if I if I go to
somebody I mean I'm trying to think of
something that I'm like totally
unqualified to talk about oh you know so
I used to skateboard when I was younger
and I really enjoyed it but I don't
I barely remember any of the terminology
and I I don't know how to do any of the
tricks anymore I have no idea about you
know where you would place your weight
or foot or anything to do those things
and let's say I go in and because
skateboarding is clearly quite popular
again and I start you know telling you
know kids about how I used to skate back
in the 80s these are what the boards are
like and you should do this and you
should do this you should do this maybe
and maybe there I am trying to talk as
if I'm authoritative right and then so
then is that lying to them if I'm
pretending to an expertise that I don't
I don't have yeah and actually this is a
really good segue to one of my points of
Andrew Wakefield it was the researcher
who saw made that paper that supposedly
showed a link between autism and
vaccines and how oh yeah he had he was a
doctor but he got stripped of that
afterwards and the research afterwards
to show that he was very sloppy in his
methods and that he should not have made
that conclusion at all and the problem
is that it has been now become like
gospel to a certain segment of the
population it is a lie that he should
have known better because of his
apparent schooling and he failed and he
and the reason why I had so much
credence was that at one point in time
he was talking in a very authoritative
manner yeah and you know something that
that brings to mind for me is perhaps
the more of the
truth because we never know all the
truth right maybe the more the truth
that we have the greater responsibility
we have then to not abuse that that
truth in order to tell lies so so if
I've actually like gone to medical
school and been a practicing physician
for a long time there's a greater onus
on me to be truthful about things
pertaining to the body and drugs and
medicine than there would be just some
person on the street or you know if you
go up to me and you ask me about
philosophy and I tell you that you know
Plato said all sorts of things that he
didn't actually say it's probably worse
for me to be doing that than it is for
my friend the guitar professor who
studies philosophy on the side as an
amateur okay right absolutely and then
one of the other problems about this is
that these things have you know
anchoring bias the first things that you
hear makes an idea stick more and
everything kind of like oh if that
that's a thing then everything else has
to go it's kind of like in negotiations
and you say oh no I thought you know I
want like you know $35,000 for your
annual salary and they're like okay
great a little thicker around and you
know it will stay around there instead
of you say forty five and they're like
oh now they have to actually you know
negotiate or something
yeah I'll tell you a kind of a funny
story I so you know my first job out of
out of graduate school was teaching in a
maximum-security prison and I was just
offered the salary that I was offered
and there wasn't any negotiation or
anything like that and it wasn't it
wasn't an awful lot of money it was like
thirty five thousand five hundred per
year and then you could get like merit
raises provided you were like publishing
and stuff like that but the merit raises
were not not very much and then the
prison education program that I was
teaching and got phased out by the state
of Indiana and there's a whole long
story to be told about that that I'm not
going to go into here and so I had to
get on the job market and one of the
places that I
not only got an interview at but would
then got a job offer at was Fayetteville
State University and this time I thought
and I didn't really have any good advice
on this from you know mentors by that
time but I thought well I'm gonna
negotiate this time and so they offered
me fifty thousand and I was like now
that's too low and then they they're
like well what would you take and I and
I I probably could have driven them up
higher but I didn't know well enough and
I said fifty-five and they're like okay
you've gotta and then you know because
all of this was public record you could
you could look and see everybody who was
earning everything in the North Carolina
system and I realized that I had
low-balled myself but I also realized
that my colleague who came in at the
exact same time as me and had two
additional years of teaching experience
and also low-balled herself a thousand
dollars less and once once it was fixed
it was you couldn't get it changed
because as soon as we came in it was
2008 and within three months of getting
there the you know the economic crisis
had worsened and all salaries were
frozen and no travel and all this other
stuff but it you know it's kind of
interesting you know when you when you
do negotiate quite often you have to
negotiate without having any clue of
what you're doing and and there you know
you're not going to get straight
information out of the people that
you're negotiating with either some
people have actually proposed having
agents for everyone agents yeah sit
negotiate on your behalf
know they actually know how it won to
negotiate into how much your skills are
worth okay they just you know they get a
small cut and they just like heck is
this like I'm the the professor guy
agent I've got all the the professors on
my on my own company and you know I'll
get the best for you I know what I could
get for you so they would be sort of
like a like a combination of a
headhunter and an agent right they'd
connect you up with the the jaw
and potentially it could just be that's
care of an attractive idea actually so
actually let's talk about deontological
and consequentialists lying okay yeah
and I don't think we'll be able to get
into too much other moral theory but
this is where one of the big division
lines runs so and we can we can place
like Immanuel Kant in one corner because
he's the one who everyone goes to and
then Jeremy Bentham and John Stuart
Mill's the utilitarians and the other
and the sort of standard line is that
Kant thinks you should never ever ever
ever ever ever ever ever ever lie
there's no exceptions you know it's it's
always a terrible thing when when you
lies as a matter of fact in in the
groundwork for the metaphysics of morals
he gives you this whole a you know
discussion of it that that lying is even
in some respect nonsensical you can't
possibly will it as a universal what he
calls a universal law of nature that we
should lie when it's convenient or
anything like that because it would
undermine the very notion of truth and
falsity if everyone were to do it so
this is pretty dramatic stuff right and
then and then in the actual metaphysics
of morals he goes a little bit further
and he says that lying is the worst
thing that a person can essentially do
in relation to themselves it's the
greatest violation of a person's duty to
themself and he talks about lying
internally and externally this goes to
the thing that you were talking about a
little bit earlier lying externally is
lying to other people lying to the world
lying internally is lying to yourself
and lying internally is worse than lying
externally not that they're not both
terrible but they're they're really bad
and he goes so far as to say that even
having a good motive or an innocuous
motive like he gives the example of
levity that doesn't excuse it so that's
that's you know a very strong
deontological meaning Duty based point
of view there are other day on tala just
like WD ross and robert goudie and the
president
would say that there there could be some
circumstances where you do need to lie
where it could be a duty but then you
would have to find some way to try to
fix the damage afterwards so for an
internal lie by way of cons is that
self-deception or just the idea that I
would say a lie and so I know that I'm
telling a lie so that's a good question
it is self-deception but in a lot of
cases it's not really effective
self-deception so and it could tie in
with the telling a lie to somebody else
so if you think about why we lie to
other people maybe I lie to you and I
tell myself that it's really a white lie
to save your feelings but the truth of
the matter is I just don't want you to
have access to that information or I'm
worried about the consequences of the
truth coming to light or something like
that so I do lie to myself right that
that's the internal lie and we can lie
to ourselves without involving other
people as well we can tell ourselves
that were oh you mentioned the
dunning-kruger effect I mean people who
who are in the bottom quartile right are
lying to themselves all the time saying
I'm so attractive I'm so brilliant I'm
so this so that and those would be now
the question is is the person
deliberately doing it or is it just sort
of like an automatic process are they
doing it to try to support their
self-esteem and Kant would say I'll
listen all of those things are really
damaging to the to the person within you
and somebody else who we were talking
about before
this you know epictetus the stoic I
think he would he would probably go
along with conte on that you know we
when we lie to ourselves we're really
doing something bad for ourselves you
know and and it's it's interesting if
you think about this because that would
rule out quite a few practices that
people sometimes do to try to motivate
themselves or
like pump themselves up in the mirror or
something yeah yeah which might which
might be helpful for accomplishing
things you know no on the other hand we
have the utilitarians and the attila
Tyrians focus on consequences and so
they want to see they're not you know
looking at just their own consequences
or their own in-group they're looking at
everybody and how they're affected and
so they say that the right thing to do
is whatever is going to promote the
general happiness meaning you know
produce the most positive outcomes and
the least negative outcomes so you know
I think we can think of a lot of cases
where people tell lies and the
justification for that will be well I
want to prevent this thing from
happening over here which would be bad
and you know in general the utilitarians
are pretty comfortable with telling lies
as a matter of fact John Stuart Mill in
on Liberty is perfectly fine with with
people telling lies in what we can call
the marketplace of ideas you know saying
things that are false because you know
ultimately the truth should should come
out of it I think he's a little
optimistic about that but but they don't
say it's just because any case of lying
to a person would produce a positive
outcomes that it's okay they do worry a
bit about your motivations and
dispositions that you're developing over
time you know so being stuck in a
situation where you'd have to lie
constantly would probably be bad for you
I think we have a moment to talk about
the nature truth well I think we should
if we do want to consider our question
and in our practice okay I have to jump
into those yeah so we got a question
which is I've always been one to think
that person should stay true to their
experience when telling a story if you
have to go out of your way to exaggerate
it a why about parts of the story then
the story clearly wasn't interesting
enough to tell so
in a recent instance when my girlfriend
was telling a story
it made me cringe when she felt the need
to lie about details to make it more
interesting I confronted her about this
alone in private sharing my thoughts as
above she did not take it well and it's
mad and in truth I feel that she is
actually the one at fault for in my eyes
essentially lying so these are two
people who probably aren't gonna do well
together over the long term I'm guessing
right but but how should we how should
we look at this is this person in the
right to be calling calling his
significant other out for embellishing
stories is this what do you think it
definitely seems to be a difference in
opinion about what is right to do in
these situations and there's a mismatch
in the modulation about like what is
good enough to say or not I guess the
thing that is not quite clear about this
and was that is the girlfriend expecting
the other able to believe the things
that she's saying it's where she or she
expecting them to think it is actually
like you know uh tall sale yeah now why
would that make a difference it's the
the intended deception you're trying to
either modulate reality or you're trying
to entertain oh there yeah and I think a
lot of people do tell stories in the
second way that you're talking about
where they they they know that
everybody's not going to buy into it and
think that this this really is the way
that things happened you know
historically or however we want to put
it but it makes for it it makes for a
good story and I mean is there some
positive good in having a good story
that people can share and laugh about
you know gather around I mean so long as
they're not actually relying upon it as
a guide to life or what they ought to do
maybe maybe there's really no problem
with that
let's see we had the film on TV industry
for a reason yeah although people use
those to rely and like give them an idea
of how to deal with the world all that
time and I think that - is a
miscalculation by the viewer yeah that's
that that's true I mean that's that's
where we get into some really
interesting in murky areas because we
can say well what what about like you
know young people who are in incredibly
media saturated environment and are
getting all sorts of crazy ideas from
the various media that we we constantly
bombard them with a lot of those are are
lies in one sense or another if they
take those on and think that those
really are truthful is it their fault
yeah I mean is there a certain point
where somebody should where you could
actually say to somebody hey you know
you know that's not real don't follow
that and where we could say well you
know you you ought to have enough common
sense to know that these stories aren't
aren't veridical and that reminds me of
like the trope of a lot of maybe it's
more in the 90s sitcoms of like the
someone wise to another person on the
story but they're doing it in order for
them to do something really good or
something I'm doing these these white
lies and at the end is like at the cause
this incredible mishap and like you know
cars are destroyed or whatever and like
but I was doing it for the best and it
was like ah yeah it was like that they
never sell lie after lie after lie right
and if you see that over and over and
over and over again you know just the
the repetition of it makes you think
that it's true like you just forget
repeated the same I'm like oh that's how
things happen like it's normal I guess
that a lie then right it's it's a lie
about lot truth and lying right so I'm
kind of sympathetic to people who
embellish although like I was saying I
in the past I was much less happy about
that
but I think we do have to be careful
about who is gonna take it in so you
wouldn't say some crazy story in front
of some perfectly credulous person
perhaps right so yeah because that could
result in really negative ends they take
that true and that's a guide for how to
deal with a situation similar to that in
future yeah so we should talk about a
practice that can be useful for four
people before we wrap up yeah so what do
you got for us so I you know I think the
self-examination is really central to
most moral traditions and you know you
can do this in a structured way like at
the end of the day or you know when you
get into a difficult situation some
people do it through journaling and I
think that you could do this by
thematize and truth and lying you could
you could ask yourself if you've really
been honest over some time period or
you've really been honest in this
exchange and you can also ask yourself
how honest you've been you know how much
did you bend the truth about the things
that you've said or other ways in which
you may have communicated as well so you
can you can think about this in a couple
different ways one thing that you can
focus on is to think about whether other
people actually were deceived and
whether that was your intent to do that
and then you can think about ways in
which other people not necessarily
automatically were deceived but could
have been deceived where things could
have gone off the rails where you you
said something you know another thing
that happens in sitcoms just to go back
to that is one person says something and
the other person misunderstands it a
little bit and then they don't correct
that misunderstanding and then they take
advantage of that misunderstanding I
think that's a way of engaging in
and lying and then the other thing that
I think is important is to you know step
back from it and you you know while
you're being brutally honest with
yourself which may be quite difficult
you have to ask yourself okay why do I
lie what what's going on with me that
that motivates me to say things that
aren't true and I know that they're not
true and I want the other person to
believe them as being true and there
could be a wide variety of motives right
it could be monetary it could be saving
one's own face it could be motivated by
some good it could because you want
people to like you that's a really
common example I think people tell lies
all the time to try to get other people
to to either like them or not dislike
them and so figuring out what makes you
tick is quite important and so by
carrying out this almost like inventory
and self-examination you can get a
handle on it and you can develop some
greater awareness that allows you then
to start making decisions and
intervening and hopefully steering
yourself towards being a bit more
truthful because truth is something you
know that that we value and and so I
think that could be a useful practice I
don't actually have a name for the
practice other than maybe you know being
honest with yourself about lying right
this kind of reminds me I did kind of
like a little pseudo Gaslight anything
or I like to just move small objects
around the room when no one else was in
the room and so the whole idea was like
I never go into trying to like steal
anything or make people like totally
misplaced it was just like oh it's it's
on that table instead of that table um
and I just like I got a kick out of it
it was like this enjoy to see them be
just confused for a moment on and then
they'd find it and and it was like this
little internal thing that I thought was
like oh that's that's perfectly fine
that's not actually hurting anyone and
I'm getting a little
you know endorphins or joy out of it
yeah and then you know one day someone
saw me do it and and point it out and
all of a sudden you get that like that
shame I kind of think oh SART talking
about like look exactly look into the
cable and now you see yourself as the
object of someone else's derision and
you're like oh that is that's exactly
how I am being seen and now I I need to
reflect upon that and sometimes it just
takes you that extra experience to be
able to reflect you know being caught in
a lie yes is an unpleasant experience
right so you know that's that's a great
example I think how a very minor thing
can can turn into something that it
didn't have any terrible consequences
but but it certainly felt like something
like that for you well we should we
should wrap up any any final thoughts
about lies do you want to tell any air
[Laughter]
so we've got a quote and so we'll leave
you the words of Ch Spurgin and why
we'll go around the world while the
truth is pulling its boots on which is
famously
misattributed to Mark Twain so we're
ending on a line right where we're
trying to bring truth to a line so thank
you all
[Music]
you